LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
déployer depuis fin 2020 en France la
technologie 5G a fait l'objet de
nombreuses controverses au cœur d'elle
les préoccupations pour la santé posés
par les ondes vous avez les problèmes de
fertilité que ce soit masculine ou faire
au féminine on a la question de
l'augmentation des cancers du cerveau en
France pour le gouvernement cette
technologie est une priorité il en va de
l'avenir économique du pays on va
expliquer débattre lever les doutes
tordre le coup à toutes les fausses
idées mais oui la France va prendre le
tournant de la 5G parce que c'est le
tournant de l'innovation l'OMS a classé
les ondes électromagnétiques en 2011
comme peut-être cancérogène pour l'homme
et ce même si les recherches
scientifiques n'ont pas pu établir de
relation de cause à effet jusqu'à lors
les niveaux d'exposition mesurés par les
experts se veulent rassurants
alors doit-on se méfier de nos
téléphones portables quels sont les
risques de la 5G c'est le thème de ce
nouveau numéro d'état de santé
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro des tas de santé on va poser une
question que peut-être précisément vous
vous êtes déjà posé la 5G est-elle
dangereuse pour la santé alors il y a eu
un débat qui a fait rage entre les
anciens et les modernes pour résumer
évidemment ça va bien au-delà mais on se
rappelle en 2020 Emmanuel Macron avait
comparé aux amis je rétrograde les
adversaires de cette technologie qui il
est vrai a beaucoup d'avantages mais il
y a beaucoup d'idées qui circulent sur
la 5G on va tenter grâce à notre invité
Olivier Merkel de faire le vrai du faux
de dire quel est le vrai du faux bonjour
à vous bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes chef d'évaluation
des risques physiques à l'encens c'est
l'agence nationale on va dire pour
résumer de sécurité merci à vous la
problématique
c'est pas son usage parce que ça tout le
monde aime bien que ça aille plus vite
éventuellement encore que c'est un débat
mais c'est surtout la nocivité
potentiel des ondes on va en parler mais
d'abord quel est votre portrait
exactement on regarde
Olivier Merkel dirige l'unité
d'évaluation des risques liés aux agents
physiques à l'Agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail l'enseest
titulaire d'un doctorat en physique il a
travaillé sur l'exposition aux ondes
depuis plus de 20 ans Allan cess son
unité regroupe des experts qui étudie
les risques pour la santé humaine venant
des champs électromagnétiques de la
lumière des nanomatériaux du bruit et
même du changement climatique
Olivier Merkel d'abord une petite
question de définition la 5G est-ce
qu'on pourrait résumer en disant que
c'est la 4G augmenté c'est ce que
certains effectivement disent en réalité
c'est peut-être beaucoup plus que ça
c'est présenté comme une technologie qui
permettra finalement beaucoup de
développement technologique de type
fonctionnement de de l'internet des
objets avec la possibilité de faire
communiquer en fait énormément d'objets
en même temps mais aussi d'avoir ce
qu'on appelle des temps de latence
c'est-à-dire des temps de communication
entre des dispositifs extrêmement
faibles et c'est ce qu'on nous promet
par exemple à la avec la voiture
autonome voilà donc ces trois aspects un
débit accru pour la téléphonie mobile
beaucoup d'objets qui communiquent en
même temps et puis la possibilité de
communiquer très rapidement la 5G elle
se déploie disant qu'elle arrose moins
en ondes électromagnétique beaucoup
moins que la 4G elle cible davantage les
appareils qui qui sont récepteurs de
saison
que promet la 5G c'est effectivement
cette capacité avec des antennes
spécifiques du coup dans certaines
bandes de fréquences d'aller chercher
l'utilisateur et de rentrer finalement
en communication uniquement ou quasiment
uniquement avec lui et donc c'est là où
on a des ce qu'on appelle les antennes
focalisées donc ils vont permettre de
réduire l'espace dans lequel on émet les
ondes électromagnétiques et d'atteindre
le téléphone de l'utilisateur c'est ça
qui va permettre vraiment d'avoir des
débits augmentés votre unité à la publie
un rapport qui est important en février
2022 qui conclut exactement dans le
texte que au vu des données disponibles
il n'y a pas de nouveaux risques avérés
avec la 5G ça veut dire quoi qu'il n'y a
pas de risque ou que vous n'aurez pas
trouvé mais ça veut pas dire qu'il y en
a pas
c'est oui la formule est effectivement
peu enfin en tout cas susciter quelques
explications peut-être ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que pour
finalement donner ce résultat on
s'appuie sur en gros 15 ans de recherche
de travaux à l'agence 15 ans d'examen de
l'ensemble de des publications
scientifiques et donc c'est
l'accumulation vraiment de toutes ces
données
examinées par des groupes de
scientifiques on ne travaille pas seul
même si on a une petite unité là qui
s'occupe effectivement des ondes
électromagnétiques mais on travaille
avec de nombreux chercheurs de nombreux
universitaires en France mais aussi dans
le monde et donc effectivement sur la 5G
ce qu'on observe c'est que on est quand
même très proche des fréquences qui sont
utilisées depuis de très nombreuses
années avec la téléphonie mobile et que
finalement les effets qu'on n'a pas vu
ou qu'on a un peu identifié dans au
cours des dernières années ne seront pas
vraisemblablement différents avec la 5G
parce qu'il y a des valeurs
réglementaires qui ont été établies à
partir desquels effectivement les ondes
électromagnétiques
peuvent être dangereuses pour la santé
on va regarder une infographie qui nous
indique comment se situe les ondes de la
5G par rapport à ces valeurs
réglementaires on garde ça
nos téléphones utilisent des ondes
électromagnétiques pour communiquer la
5G c'est donc la cinquième génération de
cette technologie elle s'ajoute à la 4G
à la 3G avec de nouvelles antennes pour
augmenter par 10 le débit et la vitesse
de connexion une vidéo de 1 Go serait
téléchargé en moins de 2 secondes au
niveau des fréquences la 5G va utiliser
une nouvelle bande à 3,5 GHz les ondes
électromagnétiques ont un spectre qui va
des ondes radio puisqu'à la lumière
visible les UV puis les rayons X ces
deux derniers sont connus pour être
cancérigènes on parle alors de
rayonnement
ionisant car ils altèrent la matière au
niveau moléculaire les fréquences de nos
téléphones sont beaucoup plus basses et
sont dites NON ionisantes a priori pas
de risque sauf qu'à forte intensité ils
peuvent créer un échauffement c'est
l'effet thermique c'est comme ça que
fonctionne nos fours à micro-ondes
cet effet thermique serait nocif pour la
santé et il se produit à des champs
d'une intensité de 254 à 431 volts par
mètre en fonction des fréquences
pour nous protéger les scientifiques ont
établi une limite de puissance à ne pas
dépasser elle est comprise entre 61 et
28 volts par mètre les niveaux moyens
des antennes 5G mesurées en France sont
de 2,3 volts par mètre bien en dessous
des limites réglementaires
alors on comprend mieux que les ans des
mises par la 5G sont très très loin des
valeurs réglementaires je prends un
exemple on est on exposé au soleil la
température de la peau augmente
forcément on prend de l'énergie c'est
pas pour autant qu'on tombe malade par
contre si on s'expose trop longtemps si
on reste sous un soleil tropical ou dans
un cabine de bronzage là on risque
vraiment des effets coup de soleil
relativement aigu et puis à long terme
au cancer de la peau bon donc là toute
la question c'est de savoir
effectivement avec les ondes
électromagnétiques c'est est-ce qu'on
est dans cette situation là donc oui on
observe effectivement quelques effets on
voit des effets de stress de cellules de
choses comme ça etc on voit certaines
modifications
notamment au niveau des des ondes
cérébrales qui sont émises quand on
téléphone pour autant aucune étude
aujourd'hui ou l'examen de l'ensemble
des études ne permet pas de déduire que
il puisse y avoir un effet sur la santé
avéré L donc aux ondes qui sont dans
notre environnement donc ça c'est très
clair ce que vous nous dites on va
revenir un peu sur le débat parce qu'il
a existé et continue évidemment d'être
animé par par certains adversaires de la
5G
vous allez voir Sébastien Avila a
recensé ça il l'a comparé à un bras de
fer reportage
et si la 5G était dangereuse pour notre
santé la question est claire mais la
réponse est moins la 5G divise pour et
contre s'affrontent
l'implantation de la 5G ressemble à un
bras de fer
parmi les contre ce médecin fin 2020
marcarazi publie un livre où il dénonce
les risques de surexposition au
rayonnement de nos téléphones portables
pour lui le passage à la 5G aggrave la
situation aujourd'hui il y a 5 milliards
d'utilisateurs sur la planète et 5
milliards de personnes qui sont des
victimes potentielles à différents
niveaux des problèmes sanitaires liés
aux ondes vous avez les problèmes de
fertilité que ce soit masculine ou faire
au féminine on a la question de
l'augmentation des cancers du cerveau en
France des risques pour la santé mais
qui manque d'arguments scientifiques
irréfutables alors les pour à l'image
d'Emmanuel Macron s'affiche comme
défenseur voir comme militants de cette
nouvelle technologie et évidemment on va
passer à la 5G je vais être très clair
on va expliquer débattre lever les
doutes tordre le cou à toutes les
fausses idées mais oui la France va
prendre le tournant de la 5G parce que
c'est le tournant de l'innovation et la
bataille s'engage les pétitions anti 5G
fleurissent des manifestations
s'organisent et certains vont même
jusqu'à brûler les premières antennes
se poursuit jusque sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale ou des députés de
l'opposition demandent à moratoire avant
l'attribution des nouvelles fréquences
5G
comme la Corée comme la Nouvelle-Zélande
oui nous allons lancer les enchères de
la 5G oui nous avons pris nos
responsabilités sanitaires
environnementales cette réponse est très
simple nous le faisons pour le pays nous
le faisons pour notre industrie nous le
faisons pour les français pour tenter de
stopper la polémique le gouvernement
saisit lands l'agence nationale doit
déterminer si oui ou non la 5G
représente un risque pour la santé et
elle doit le faire vite trop vite dit
certains octobre 2020 sans attendre le
rapport de landeces le gouvernement
annonce la vente des fréquences qui
rapportent près de 2,8 milliards d'euros
à l'État aujourd'hui l'État français met
les États en général sont dans une forme
de de schizophrénie de conflit d'intérêt
énorme puisque d'un côté elles vendent
des fréquences à des industriels de la
téléphonie mobile et de l'autre entre
guillemets
ne pourrait pas les les contraintes
finalement à ne pas poser d'antenne
relais vous pouvez pas vendre à
quelqu'un quelque chose et l'empêcher
ensuite de pouvoir l'utiliser pour les
contre le gouvernement serait jugé
partit sans prendre le temps de la
réflexion ce sociologue a étudié la
controverse sur la 5G pour lui les
contre dénoncent moins la technologie
que la manière dont elle est imposée à
la population il y a une préoccupation
sur le fait qu'on
au moment où on déploie on n'en sait pas
suffisamment il y a une sorte de
simultanéité entre
l'arrivée d'une technologie et puis la
production de données de mesure et de
recherche sur les effets de cette
technologie
et donc le sentiment est que on devrait
en savoir plus
avant de avant de déployer lorsque sort
le rapport de landeces la 5G déployée
depuis plus d'un an sur le territoire
difficile alors de faire marche arrière
les experts sur la base de centaines de
publications scientifiques ont donc
conclu sans surprise le déploiement de
la 5G dans la bande de fréquence autour
de 3,5 GHz ne constitue pas un nouveau
risque pour la santé
d'où cette question qui fâche landeces
est-elle vraiment indépendante des choix
du gouvernement je pense pas qu'il y ait
de pression directe sur lancès pour
rendre des travaux qui aillent dans un
sens ou dans un autre par contre il y a
une pression du contexte qui est
le déploiement anticipé de la
technologie il y a un calendrier il faut
faire cette cette état des connaissances
dans un temps imparti assez court
finalement étant donné la quantité de
données et d'études à passer à passer en
revue c'est une forme de c'est une forme
de pression travail et travailler vite
une chose est sûre plus de temps aurait
permis à l'anxess de mieux finaliser son
expertise avant l'attribution des
fréquences ce qui aurait eu pour
avantage de couper court aux critiques
alors Olivier Merkel ce qu'on entend à
la fin c'est que vous à l'un de ces vous
travailleriez sous une forme de pression
en fait le fait de devoir travailler
vite et bien sa disqualifierait de près
ou loin votre le résultat de vos études
qu'est-ce que vous répondez justement au
final tout notre travail à l'agence
c'est de se dégager de cette pression
bien sûr qu'elle existe bien sûr qu'il y
a une pression sociale
économique du gouvernemental précédé
bien sûr et simplement il faut bien
comprendre que évaluer les risques d'une
nouvelle technologie qui se met en place
ça prend du temps c'est pour ça qu'on
réclame justement nous effectivement le
temps de faire les choses correctement
indépendant ou pas on travaille de
manière totalement indépendante c'est à
dire que le gouvernement typiquement n'a
aucun regard sur les travaux que nous
menons nous travaillons uniquement donc
avec des groupes d'experts nous
répondons devant à personne finalement
de la manière dont nous travaillons
je voulais repoussiez mais on essaie le
travail il est fait vraiment on va se
clos ça c'est extrêmement important dans
un bocal complètement c'est-à-dire qu'on
sélectionne des experts avec une
attention extrêmement pointue sur les
liens d'intérêt porté par ces experts
d'ailleurs leur nom ne sont pas connus
pendant le temps de l'expertise et puis
bien sûr après c'est le l'autre aspect
c'est l'ouverture c'est à dire que là au
contraire on est dans la transparence on
livre tout tous les résultats de nos de
nos travaux sous la forme de rapport
sous la forme de synthèse d'avis tout ça
est public c'était important que ce soit
dit parce que effectivement vous devez
souvent vous justifier de ça alors
question précise on voit dans le
reportage à un médecin lanceur d'alerte
je sais pas si vous le connaissez
d'ailleurs si il est connu comme le loup
blanc il parle d'augmentation de tumeurs
au cerveau peut-être lié au téléphone
portable cette fois est-ce que il y a un
lien qui a été établi ou pas
effectivement un certain nombre d'études
épidémiologiques donc qui portent sur
des populations qui ont regardé
donc pour état de santé à chercher à
comprendre ce qui pouvait être nocif
pour la santé reportage
région parisienne non loin du quartier
de la Défense quartier dansément peuplé
et bien couvert par la 5G dans cet
appartement un expert en radioprotection
traque les ondes grâce à cette étrange
apparaît à l'intérieur
actuellement on est dans les 170
micromètres
dès qu'on ouvre la fenêtre
tout de suite à l'extérieur on est à
plus de 1000 microwatts sachant qu'il y
a des pics à plus de 7000 pour comparer
ces valeurs aux limites réglementaires
il faut utiliser un tableau de
conversion on obtient alors que 170
micromètres correspondent à 0,25 volts
par mètre et 7000 microwatts
correspondent à 1,62 volts par mètre la
limite la plus proche est de 28 volts
par mètre on en est donc loin cependant
pour lui même à ces niveaux les ondes
peuvent poser problème aux personnes
sensibles aussi il leur propose une
panoplie de matériaux pour réduire leurs
expositions aux ondes dévoilages
d'étoiles ou encore des peintures de
blindage servent à lutter contre ce
qu'il considère comme une réelle
pollution aggravée par l'arrivée de la
5G pour certains cette pollution
s'apparente à un calvaire ça crée de
l'inflammation et ça pousse sur divers
symptômes
pour les personnes les plus sensibles ce
qu'on appelle l'électrosensibilité qui
cette électroensensibilité peut être
très grave et certaines personnes sont
obligées de partir loin des villes mais
d'autres ça pose uniquement des
problèmes de maux de tête des problèmes
articulaires des problèmes gastriques
des pertes de concentration
de la suractivité
des symptômes qui seraient accentués à
proximité des antennes relais avec le
déploiement de la 5G les antennes
relaient sont en train de fleurir un peu
partout en France on en compte
aujourd'hui plus de 36 000 en plein
centre de Paris le toit de ce bâtiment
accueille l'une de ses antennes relais
une équipe d'ingénieurs vient vérifier
si les ont émises par l'antenne sont
conformes à la réglementation
est l'agence gouvernementale chargée de
mesurer l'exposition aux ondes équipées
d'appareils sophistiqués et calibré ils
font office d'autorité premier test sur
toutes les fréquences alors les antennes
qu'on mesure ici bah c'est l'ensemble
des émissions et donc principalement les
antennes de téléphones mobiles qui sont
installés sur le toit de cet immeuble et
on voit qu'on a ici un niveau autour de
trois volts par mètre puis vient une
mesure spécifique à la 5G il faut
utiliser pour cela un téléphone portable
pour être certain d'activer les bonnes
fréquences
donc je lance le téléchargement ici d'un
fichier de 1 Go
et on voit ici l'activité qui monte sur
la partie du spectre 5G dans la bande 3
4 3,8 GHz et le niveau est monté autour
de 0,3 volts par mètre donc c'est niveau
sont très en dessous des valeurs limites
réglementaires qui varient entre 28 et
61 volts par mètre selon les bandes de
fréquences
la NFR se veut rassurante les antennes
émettent peu d'ondes contrairement au
téléphone l'équipe reproduit
l'expérience mais en mesurant cette fois
les ondes directement émises par le
portable
donc là je vais
uploader un fichier de 1 Go et on va
voir ce que ça fait sur sur le spectre
des pics d'intensité apparaissent sur
l'appareil
les antennes de nos téléphones émettent
beaucoup d'ondes
pour en savoir plus nous nous sommes
rendus dans ce laboratoire de la NFR
cette machine futuriste simule
l'absorption des ondes par le corps
humain c'est ce qu'on appelle le DAS ou
débit d'absorption spécifique
sur la tête de ce mannequin des capteurs
réagissent aux antennes nos téléphones
ont généralement deux l'une pour la 4G
l'autre pour la 5G donc l'antenne 5G se
situe tout en haut sur la partie droite
de l'oreille l'antenne 4G se situe tout
en bas du téléphone et est en face de la
bouche sur l'écran apparaît la mesure en
rouge ou les ondes sont les plus
intenses et c'est l'antenne 4G qui
rayonne sur une plus grande zone 4G est
plus forte que l'antenne 5G bien que
l'antenne 5G est plus proche de la tête
et le résultat du DAS combiné et de
0,057 ce qui est très très très très
faible par rapport à la limite de 2
Watts par kilo là pour le directeur de
la NFR ceci s'explique par le mode de
fonctionnement du réseau qui utilise en
même temps la 4G et la 5G
quand le téléphone fonctionne en 5G on
va avoir l'antenne 4G qui est là pour
maintenir la connexion et l'antenne 5G
qui est là pour transmettre les données
et finalement c'est l'antenne 4G qui
fonctionne en permanence qui va émettre
le plus une antenne 5G qui fonctionne
dans une bande 5G va émettre finalement
une minorité de la durée elle va émettre
un cinquième du temps donc elle va
émettre moins aujourd'hui la 5G
n'augmente donc pas les risques
puisqu'elle s'appuie sur la 4G mais
demain quand la 5G sera autonome ce sera
peut-être une autre histoire
alors Monsieur Merkel dans ce reportage
on nous redit j'ai envoyé déjà tout à
l'heure dans l'infographie c'est qu'on
est très très loin des niveaux
des niveaux d'onde réglementaires qui
présentera un danger c'est très très
très loin mais
on nous conseille quand même de nous
éloigner de notre portable de notre
téléphone portable il est là le danger
la question est la recherche s'en occupe
et donc par prudence dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui tout le monde a un téléphone
dans la mesure où les enfants
seront beaucoup plus exposés que nous on
sait aussi que les enfants typiquement
absorbent un peu plus les ondes
électromagnétiques et donc le message de
prudence qui est délivré par l'agence
depuis longtemps depuis quasiment 2005
2007-2009 c'est de dire attention aux
enfants en tout cas soyons prudents avec
les enfants limitons l'exposition des
enfants au téléphone mobile et ça peut
être facile il suffit de l'éloigner en
fait c'est le je dirais la méthode la
plus simple gratuite de limiter son
exposition aux ondes qu'on soit un
enfant ou qu'on soit inquiet finalement
on éloigne le téléphone on utilise un
kit main libre mais aujourd'hui déjà il
y a des personnes qui se disent très
électrosensibles qui vont chez le
médecin qui ont des symptômes des maux
de tête à répétition
et ils disent voilà c'est lié aux ondes
qu'elles arrivent dans un endroit elle
ici un portable je peux pas rentrer
elles prennent pas l'avion c'est hyper
handicapant c'est personne là elles ont
un mal rare particulier où on est dans
l'ordre du de l'autosuggestion ce qu'on
peut dire effectivement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois
malheureusement la science n'apporte pas
de réponse définitive à cette question
c'est à dire qu'on ne le fait pas de
lien entre le fait d'être exposé aux
ondes électromagnétiques et les
symptômes qui sont déclarés par ces
personnes pour autant ce qui est très
important à dire c'est que ces symptômes
sont complètement réels et que la
qualité de vie en fait de ces personnes
là elle est extrêmement impactée plus ou
moins d'ailleurs il y a divers degrés il
y a des gens qui continuent finalement à
vivre à peu près normalement avec et
puis d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus impactés et donc du coup
l'action finalement c'est une action des
pouvoirs publics qui doivent prendre ce
problème là en charge sérieux prendre en
charge les symptômes à défaut de pouvoir
établir absolument que c'est lié aux
ondes les prendre au sérieux les prendre
en charge c'est important merci beaucoup
Olivier merkest et passionnant on n'a
pas fini de se poser toutes ces
questions là si j'ai c'est bientôt ah
oui bien sûr et puis la 7g sûrement plus
tard
pour pouvoir étudier donc là si j'ai
après la 5G c'est logique toujours plus
loin toujours plus vite merci beaucoup
Olivier Merkel merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis à très bientôt sur SCP pour
état de santé
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé